tomorrow's inauguration will look a bit
different than other inaugurations in
recent years we know that
president-elect joe biden will deliver a
speech from the traditional spot at the
capitol we've seen that
but the crowds will be replaced by sea
of flags we have never seen that
then he's going to travel to arlington
national cemetery with three former
presidents
before returning for a very scaled-down
parade
chip reid looks at how inaugurations
have changed over the years
kennedy aye george herbert walker bush
it's a moment
that focuses the attention of a nation
so help me god congratulations mr
president
that exact moment when the
president-elect finishes that oath
he is the president of the united states
and the previous president
is simply a citizen presidential
historian doris kearns goodwin says that
even without the customary crowds and
galas
this inauguration like so many others
will mark a dramatic
change in direction every inauguration
is a new beginning it's almost like a
spiritual beginning
in 1933 speaking amid the great
depression
franklin delano roosevelt issued an
enduring call
for national resilience the only thing
we have to
fear is fear itself
the most important thing he said was
that there had been an absence of
national leadership and he was going to
provide
that leadership it produced a change of
mood in the country at large
do you think that joe biden is being
inaugurated at a time that at least in
some ways is similar
i think that the crisis has many
similarities the crisis provides an
opportunity for a leader to mobilize the
resources of the nation
and if the leader is up to it and if the
citizens are up to it
that is when change can really happen
the torch has been passed
to a new generation the dawning of a new
era was also
john f kennedy's central theme in 1961
more than two decades younger than his
predecessor he delivered
a memorable invitation to public
not what your country can do for you
ask what you can do for your country
there's no question that he tapped
something that was already there
and it meant that young people felt a
sense of doing something for their
country
hi ronald reagan in 1981 ronald reagan
changed the look of the modern
inauguration
directly in front of me the monument to
a monumental man
moving it from the east steps of the
capitol to the grand west front with its
stunning view
of the national mall while calling for a
major shift
in the nation's politics government is
not the solution to our problem
government is the problem and as his
defeated rival
jimmy carter looked on do you think that
president trump's decision
not to attend is genuinely harmful to
american democracy it's really important
for the
president to come to his successors
inauguration
what it symbolizes is that he's
accepting that this has happened and to
not do it
i think is really leaving a blank in
democracy
and really hurting the exercise of this
extremely
wonderful moment also missing this time
is what usually happens
behind the scenes there were visits of
the families to the white house
letters have been exchanged on the last
day of the presidency
the sense really of being a part of
welcoming the new person
into what is the people's home all of
those rituals are gone by the wayside
as a former vice president joe biden has
been part of the pageantry before
and while this event will look different
his words will still
carry historic significance what do you
think he needs to learn
from previous inaugurations all of those
great inaugural addresses were not just
the leaders saying this is what i'm
going to do
they're asking the country to respond
and i think it's that linkage that he
has to make
because that's what an inauguration is
it's a new leader taking office
but it's a citizenry that's looking
perhaps for a new beginning
the last president who refused to attend
the inauguration of his successor was
andrew johnson 152 years ago
and president trump and andrew johnson
have one other big thing in common
they are two of the three presidents to
be impeached
anthony maybe not a note in history you
want to be aligned with chip thank you
very much